От-такий він, бункер!
Друзі, всім привіт!
А пам’ятаєте, у першій серії відеоблогу
я проїхав на велосипеді
повз урядовий бункер у виноградниках на випадок ядерної війни?
Згодом у коментарях ви просили повернутися
у бункер і показати його зсередини
Ну що ж, сьогодні я тут, щоб дослідити цю споруду
і з’ясувати, як німцям вдалося перетворити
секретний об’єкт на популярну туристичну пам’ятку
Напівтемрява, важкі гермодвері
температура +12
Тут на випадок ядерної війни з СРСР
мало заховатися все керівництво тодішньої ФРН
Блукаючи коридорами урядового бункера
занурюєшся в атмосферу холодної війни
Ніби на машині часу потрапляєш
в епоху протистояння
блоку НАТО і країн Варшавського договору
Бункер почали будувати у 1960 році
закінчили мегапроект у 1971-му
А ще через чверть століття
бункер втратив статус секретного об'єкта
Нині ж потрапити сюди може
кожен відвідувач музею
в який, власне, переобладнали будівлю
Правда, побачити можна лише найцікавіші кімнати
які навмисне розмістили
на відрізку тунелю завдовжки 200 метрів
Адже загальна довжина бункера вражає
Ви тільки послухайте
*Хлясь*
*Чутно довге відлуння*
Звук пішов на 17 кілометрів вглиб
Саме така довжина тунелів бункера
Директорка музею Гайке Голлундер
пропонує ще ефектніший варіант
*Бабах!*
*Чутно гучну луну*
У такий спосіб сьогодні у бункері
розважають дитячі екскурсії
Загальну суму витрат на побудову бункера
оцінюють майже у два з половиною мільярди євро
Це найдорожчий державний об’єкт в історії ФРН
У 1997 році
аби компенсувати хоч частину цих витрат
держава навіть намагалася продати
підземне місто приватному власнику
Було 16 серйозних пропозицій
потенційні покупці планували
зробити тут підземну дискотеку
чи ферму з вирощування шампіньйонів
однак найпривабливішою була пропозиція голландського підприємця
створити тут підземний парк розваг
Проте через велику небезпеку у разі пожежі
голландець передумав будувати тут
"підземний Діснейленд"
Тим часом німецька влада вирішила
демонтувати в бункері все обладнання
щоб не допустити забруднення ґрунтових вод
які почали проникати в комплекс
після відключення насосів
Зрештою скрізь, крім 200 метрів музею
залишили лише голі бетонні стіни
16 з половиною мільйонів євро коштувала перебудова бункера на музей
І от вже 10 років вражені відвідувачі
слухають подробиці облаштування секретного об’єкту від екскурсоводів
Тут можна було проводити операції
Це трохи лячно, але ось тут є
набір інструментів для невідкладної ампутації
а також оцей червоний набір для інтубації
Це демонструє спектр поранень, до яких готувалися
А у шафі можна побачити практично всі види ліків
які на той час могла запропонувати
німецька фармацевтика
Тут же ж в медичному блоці -
стоматологічний кабінет
Директорка музею дозволяє проникнути
під захисне скло
і доторкнутися до експонатів
Цей стоматологічний кабінет був зроблений
за останнім словом техніки
Ви тільки подивіться на цю бормашину
вона могла працювати як від електрики,
так і без неї
Далі - харчовий блок з консервованою їжею тривалого зберігання
фарбованими стінами і вагами
як у радянському гастрономі
Гайке Голлундер демонструє штаб,
з якого керували навчаннями
Магнітики для настінної залізної мапи
противник СРСР і країни Варшавського договору
жовто-гарячого кольору
війська НАТО - синього
Йдемо до центральної кімнати управління
з якої можна стежити за роботою усіх систем
Ось відкривання і закривання дверей
Зелений означає "безпечно", але двері зачинені
і через них неможливо пройти
Червоний означає "небезпеку",
але можна пройти всередину
В часи холодної війни раз на два роки в бункері
проводили масштабні навчання на випадок ядерного удару
Ролі перших осіб, зокрема, федерального президента і канцлера
виконували чиновники середньої ланки
У бункері є телестудія для звернення
президента і канцлера до народу
У президента були найбільші апартаменти,
яскрава кімната для переговорів
перукарня і навіть єдина у бункері ванна
У канцлера був лише особистий душ
А це загальний душ для тих, хто прийшов ззовні
За ретельністю його прийняття
через віконце з автомобільним склоочисником спостерігав контролер
Цікаво, що сценарій навчань був продуманий
лише на перші 30 днів після початку ядерної війни
Сучасних відвідувачів це дещо шокує
Ідея того, що тут передбачалося
упродовж 30 днів керувати
та визначати долю нашої країни
не включає не менш важливого аспекту,
а що ж станеться після цих 30 днів
Не хотів би я уявляти собі
що відбувалося в голові тих людей
які в ті часи на повному серйозі проводили тут
навчання на той випадок,
якщо буде здійснено ядерну атаку
А я також виріс з цим уявленням
І коли в принципі усьому кінець,
тоді вже не треба було б далі нічого планувати
Директорка музею розповідає
ще більш вражаючу деталь
жоден з трьох тисяч керівників
міністрів і топ-чиновників,
для яких були місця у бункері
не міг взяти сюди членів своєї родини
Моторошне відчуття
Коли б я ще поїздив на велосипеді
у ядерному бункері?
Чуєте, як скрипить?
Ця модель - теж музейний експонат
На таких вєліках їздили 140 працівників бункера,
які підтримували його життєдіяльність щодня
Обслуговували керівництво держави
мешканці мальовничого селища Арвайлер
які потай ходили під землю на роботу
У разі ядерного удару вони теж
не могли б взяти із собою родини
Згідно з документами, бункер міг витримати вибух бомби з зарядом
як у тієї, яку США скинули на Хіросіму
Потужність радянських зарядів
була у сотні разів більшою
Тож у разі прямого попадання шансів
вижити в бункері не було
А про місце розташування урядового бункера ФРН
спецслужба НДР "штазі" знала вже у 1966 році
Її шпигун навіть працював у бункері
Абсурдність шалених витрат на цей об’єкт
можна порівняти лише з не менш абсурдною законспірованою
фразою для перевірки телетайпів
Щотижня купуйте чотири хороші і зручні хутра
О, серйозний звук
Ну що ж
закриваємо бункер
Повертаєм ключ
і вперед
і тримаєм
Лише 10 секунд
і 25-тонні двері закривають бункер
Завдяки мільйонним вкладенням німцям вдалося
зберегти унікальну пам’ятку
холодної війни
і зробити її привабливою для туристів
Щоправда, прибутковим цей проект
для держави так і не став
Щотижня тут буває до 35 відвідувачів
Дитячий квиток коштує 4 євро, дорослий - 9 євро
Отриманих грошей, а це 100 тисяч на рік
вистачає лише на потреби музею
Як на мене, колишній урядовий бункер
заслуговує більшої уваги
Однак не всі знають про існування цього об’єкта
Ось такі таблички-вказівники - це і вся реклама
найсекретнішого місця у ФРН
за часів холодної війни
Сподіваюсь, ви відчули себе, як на екскурсії
і отримали незабутнє враження від цього унікального місця
Друзі, пишіть, що ще ви хочете знати про життя у Німеччині
і я обов'язково покажу це в наступній серії
До зустрічі!